[Musica]
buon pomeriggio a tutti e grazie
dell'applauso dell'accoglienza parliamo
di sogni oggi parliamo di sogni che sono
collegati a come te ma cerchiamo di
capire cosa sono queste come te come
questi sogni sono diventati realtà
nel nostro caso le comete sono per gli
scienziati gli oggetti che sono i
rimasugli della formazione del sistema
solare andando a esplorare queste come
te gli scienziati cosa pensano di fare
pensano di scoprire come si è formato il
sistema solare come si sono formati i
nostri pianeti e infine in fondo come si
è formata la vita è sempre la domanda
che ci poniamo da quando se esistiamo
ma dove sono le comete cosa sono questi
rimasugli sono fondamentalmente ai
confini del nostro sistema solare ma i
confini del nostro sistema solare
non sono i pianeti come li conosciamo
noi e ben oltre il confine del nostro
sistema solare della maggior parte delle
comete sono in questa nuvola di york che
si trova al confine o a metà strada tra
il nostro sistema solare e il prossimo
sistema solare
ecco queste come te sono troppo lontane
noi con la nostra missione rosetta siamo
andati ad avvicinarle una che è stata
intrappolata all'interno del sistema
solare tra giove e la terra ma come
abbiamo fatto come abbiamo fatto a
decidere questa cosa dei sogni nascono
da lontano nascono in questo caso metà
nella prima metà degli anni ottanta in
quegli anni li per me la priorità era
ancora il calcio platini era il mio
idolo non pensavo le comete non pensavo
al volo spaziale però c'erano scienziati
magari anche alla fine della loro
carriera che già sognavano oltre
volevano fare una missione di
esplorazione cometaria e quello è quello
che noi abbiamo realizzato negli ultimi
30 anni un sogno durato 30 anni che
abbiamo portato a termine
cosa abbiamo fatto in questi 30 anni
abbiamo costruito il nostro satellite
ci abbiamo messo una ventina d'anni per
convincerci si potesse fare una ventina
un'altra decina d'anni per costruirlo e
10 anni per arrivare alla cometa in
questa animazione vedete il volo di
rosetta dieci anni rosetta impiegato
dieci anni a raggiungere la cometa e
molti pensano che sia la distanza
ovviamente le gioca un ruolo ma quello
che abbiamo impiegato molto a fare ea
dare a rosetta la giusta velocità per
avvicinare la cometa nella sua orbita ma
come abbiamo fatto che abbiamo rubato
energia i pianeti come si fa si fa
passare satellite vicino a dei pm al
pianeta nel nostro caso abbiamo
sorvolato la terra tre volte in questi
dieci anni una volta marte e abbiamo
rubato energia a l'orbita del pianeta
attraverso la forza di gravità forza di
gravità l'abbiamo usata come mezzo per
trasferire l'energia orbitale del
pianeta alla sonda e lanciare la sonda
sempre più lontano nel sistema solare
quello che abbiamo praticamente fatto
abbiamo reso un po più lungo il nostro
anno solare
abbiamo rallentato la terra quasi che
potessimo rallentare il nostro il nostro
tempo dopo dieci anni di biagio siamo
arrivati finalmente in prossimità del
nostro obiettivo ci abbiamo impiegato
dieci anni e nel maggio del 2014 a una
distanza di 2 milioni di chilometri
dalla nostra cometa
abbiamo cominciato a osservarla con le
telecamere di bordo la vedete muoversi
in questa in questa piccola animazione è
cominciare a diventare attiva cosa vuol
dire attiva la cometa è un miscuglio di
simil rocce molto molto porosa
immaginate come una pietra pomice
impregnata di ghiaccio di acqua di
ghiaccio di anidride carbonica di
monossido di carbonio e altri elementi
impregnata e quando questo oggetto si
avvicina al sole l'energia del sole lo
scalda e questo calore fa sublimare
questo ghiaccio diciamo evaporare anche
se tecnicamente non è completamente
corretto e questo crea la famosa chioma
delle comete e questa chiaro ma
racchiude le proprie segreti che
volevamo andare ad esplorare
quando siamo arrivati in prossimità
della cometa un paio di mesi più tardi
abbiamo trovato questo oggetto
completamente fuori da ogni logica che
ci poteri ce l'aspettavamo completamente
diverso una forma così bizzarra questo
oggetto è grosso circa 5 km
se volete rendere un'idea pensate le
alpi il monte bianco è più o meno grosso
5 km ecco questo è un oggetto grosso più
o meno come il monte bianco vedete
quella parete tra i due
i due elementi principali dell'oggetto e
come una parete di mille metri delle
nostre alpi ma per esplorare questo
oggetto bisogna volare in prossimità nel
nostro del uno dei nostri obiettivi era
anche atterrare sull'oggetto con una
piccola sonda attaccata alla sonda madre
rosetta la sonda file che poi atterrato
sulla cometa ma per fare questo bisogna
prima esplorare la cometa per noi era un
mondo sconosciuto
quando lanciamo satellite lo mettiamo in
orbita intorno alla terra oro anche lo
lanciamo a marte di questi oggetti
conosciamo tutto siamo in grado di
volare intorno a questi oggetti nel caso
della commetterà molto molto diverso
caso la caletta abbiamo dovuto prima
caratterizzare l'ambiente in cui siamo
andati a volare volando c il centro cosa
abbiamo dovuto fare abbiamo dovuto
volare con queste traiettorie
stranissime che vedete rappresentata in
questa animazione in prossimità della
cometa e carpirne le proprietà fisiche
fondamentalmente ne cito una molto
semplice alla massa per sapere a che
velocità io devo volare in orbita
intorno a un oggetto devo conoscerne la
massa il peso diciamo così ma come
faccio a misurare il peso della cometa
beh noi abbiamo fatto delle tare attore
che lambivano la cometa e vedendo come
la forza di gravità della cometa per
turbava la nostra traiettoria ne abbiamo
derivata la massa 10 miliardi di
tonnellate alla massa della cometa e con
questi parametri nel giro di poche
settimane siamo poi stati in grado di
mettere la nostra sonda madre con tutti
gli strumenti scientifici dei nostri
scienziati in orbita a questo oggetto
misterioso
come dicevo prima uno dei nostri
obiettivi anche anche atterrare con una
piccola sonda sulla superficie della
cometa questo un ulteriore difficoltà
parlavo prima di monte bianco
beh immaginate un aereo che vola una
quota di 22 chilometri sopra monte
bianco a bordo una lavatrice lander
filerà più o meno grosso come una
lavatrice e lo deve far scendere su un
ghiacciaio del monte bianco questa
lavatrice non sa se nessun sistema di
guida di propulsione viene buttata
gettata dal finestrino dell'aereo
ecco quello è quello che abbiamo fatto
noi con l'atterraggio di file sulla
cometa abbiamo dovuto praticamente
sparare o lasciar cadere file sulla
superficie della cometa da una quota di
22 chilometri per rendere un pochino
l'idea di cosa stiamo parlando di quali
dimensioni stiamo parlando di che numeri
stiamo parlando ho pensato di
rappresentare questa questo evento
questa situazione in questo modo
immaginate che la terra sia grossa come
una pallina da tennis in questa scala
la luna è grossa più o meno come un
cesso bollito e se io le metto a una
distanza relativa di un metro e mezzo
quindi a questa distanza
questo mi rappresenta la loro distanza
nello spazio in questa scala
ora prendiamo la nostra cometa che era
grosso 5 km decisamente più piccola
della terra e della luna mese io prendo
la cometa la metto in questa scala devo
rappresentarla così prendo un capello
umano di quelli sottili e se già spesso
è già troppo grosso ne taglia una
fettina sottilissima e questa è la mia
cometa nello spazio
bene ora devo ammettere alla cometa 500
milioni di chilometri di distanza 500
milioni di chilometri di distanza in
questa scala e due chilometri all'ora
prendiamo la nostra fetta di capello
umano e la mettiamo san luca e li
vogliamo atterrare con lander file che
era grosso un metro praticamente quello
che abbiamo fatto noi a 500 milioni di
chilometri di distanza in questo caso è
come se avessimo fatto atterrare
comandando rosetta da una pallina da
tennis una molecola di emoglobina su una
fetta di capello umano messa su san luca
2 km da qua questo è quello che abbiamo
fatto
ecco se noi fossimo stati il nostro
nauta a bordo di file mentre scendeva
verso la cometa avremmo visto questa
immagine questa immagine sono montate in
tempo reale quindi vedete anche
proiettata alla distanza dalla
superficie e la superficie che si
avvicina molto lentamente file scendeva
con una velocità di circa un metro al
secondo e la velocità a cui noi
camminiamo molto molto lentamente perché
la cometa pur essendo 10 miliardi di
tonnellate ha una massa estremamente
piccola in termini spaziali ha una
densità che meno circa quella della metà
dell'acqua se prendo la cometa la metto
nel in un oceano galleggia e quindi
attira molto molto lentamente file sulla
sua superficie
e questa è la fase finale della discesa
di file vedete che la superficie a pian
piano si avvicina poi abbiamo dovuto
guardare dove fila era atterrato e
sfortunatamente abbiamo trovato questa
immagine abbiamo trovato le impronte del
carrello di atterraggio di file sulla
superficie della cometa ma file non era
in quel punto prima di dirvi un paio di
cose su cosa ha fatto file mi piace
pensare che questo evento di file
atterrato sulla cometa sia un po una
pietra miliare nella storia del volo
spaziale esattamente come questa
impronta lasciata da qualcun altro in un
altro posto nel nostro sistema solare
file è riuscito ad atterrare sulla
superficie della cometa ci ha inviato
questa immagine che vedete questa
immagine che vedete è la superficie
della cometa purtroppo file rimbalzato
sulla superficie della cometa è andato a
depositarsi in un posto diverso da
quello che noi avevamo pianificato
ciò nonostante ha funzionato
perfettamente per tre giorni ha fatto
tutte quasi tutte le sue acquisizioni
scientifiche
in queste immagini vedete una parte del
carrello di atterraggio di file e queste
rocce chiamiamole così della cometa che
stanno alla distanza e circa 80
centimetri dall'obiettivo della macchina
fotografica lo scienziato responsabile
di queste armi ha detto quel rimbalzo è
stata una bene b e benedizione per noi
perché non siamo atterrati in una zona
piatta siamo andati infilarci una specie
di crepaccio in una caverna dove io ho
trovato materiale che è vecchio 4,7
miliardi di anni 80 centimetri dalla mia
mia macchina fotografica ed era
esattamente quello che
volevo vedere la missione rosetta non
era soltanto file ha fatto tante altre
cose aveva un set di strumentazione
scientifica a bordo che ha continuato
esplorare la cometa nella sua orbita
intorno al sole più la cometa si
avvicinava al sole più diventava attiva
più emanava questi gas e metteva questi
gas e quindi nostri strumenti hanno
osservato tutta questa attività ma
soprattutto hanno annusato tanto
l'ambiente ritorna la cometa rilevando
tutti i componenti essenziali della
cometa
lo scorso anno la missione è arrivata
alla sua fine la cometa sarebbe
ritornata nello spazio
diciamo profondo nelle alle distanze di
giove per noi non era più possibile far
funzionare la sonda e la sonda madre
rosetta abbiamo fatto atterrare sulla
cometa
ma pochi giorni prima di atterrare siamo
riusciti a prendere queste immagini dove
abbiamo finalmente trovate lander file
sulla superficie della cometa quando
vedete incastrato nel suo crepaccio
nella sua grotta dove ci ha dato questi
dati scientifici incredibili
ora io volevo fare il pilota militare
nella mia carriera far volare una son
detta il planetaria è una soddisfazione
immensa ma non siamo andati lì né per
guardare le foto né per dare
soddisfazione al mio al nostro ego di
piloti di sonde interplanetarie siamo
andati lì con domande molto più
fondamentale lo dicevo all'inizio chi
siamo da dove veniamo come si è formato
il nostro sistema solare gli scienziati
cominciano a darci qualche risposta
oltre a descrivere quello che hanno
osservato cominciano ad elaborare
qualche teoria sulla formazione del
sistema solare sulla formazione della
vita ad esempio hanno trovato ossigeno
molecolare sulla cometa l'ossigeno
molecolare estremamente reattivo nello
spazio e non può resistere non poteva
resistere alla formazione del sistema
solare del sole
quindi la cometa con l'ossigeno
molecolare intrappolato esisteva prima
della formazione del sole non è più un
rimasuglio della formazione del sistema
solare esisteva già prima hanno trovato
anche aminoacidi molecole prebiotiche i
mattoni delle proteine quindi mattoni
della nostra vita
ma se mettiamo insieme queste due
informazioni e queste due cose che sono
gli ingredienti fondamentali della vita
sono erano presenti nella cometa o nelle
comete prima della formazione del sistem
ma solare beh allora ci dice che questi
ingredienti non sono specifici della
nostra terra non sono specifici del
nostro sistema solare ma ci dicono che
succede che cioè che sono universali
quindi potete immaginare voi cosa può
significare hanno trovato anche lo xenon
xeno un gas che esistente sulla terra ma
nella nostra atmosfera una composizione
isotopica diversa da quella che c'e nel
mantello terrestre che non si riesce a
spiegare perché o come possa essere
questo xenon nell'atmosfera
beh se noi prendiamo lo xenon che è
sulla cometa che immaginiamo che questo
sia stato trasferito alla terra con un
bombardamento di comete come molto
probabilmente è stato e lo prendiamo in
una certa percentuale che ci spiega
quello che abbiamo nella nostra
stratosfera beh allora questo ci dice
che l'uno per cento dell'acqua che
abbiamo sulla terra è stato portato
dalle comete e siccome l'uno per cento
della massa almeno argomenti ha fatto di
materiali organici e di e molecole
prebiotiche di amminoacidi ci dice con
bombardamento di comete sulla terra ha
generato grosse concentra può aver
generato grosse concentrazioni di questi
materiali e quindi può aver dato origine
alla vita sulla terra
questo è quello che ci ha raccontato la
la missione rosetta è stata come dicevo
prima la realizzazione di un sogno ma
fondamentalmente il grosso messaggio di
una cosa del genere che non dobbiamo
fermare la curiosità umana
quello è quello che continuiamo a fare e
continueremo a fare negli anni a venire
stiamo preparando nuove missioni nuove
missioni che continuano su questa linea
sfortunatamente lo dico sfortunatamente
perché una passione ormai per queste
come te non nel campo cometarie ma
stiamo preparando una missione che va a
mercurio si chiama bepicolombo la
vogliamo lanciare l'anno prossimo per
esplorare il pianeta più vicino al sole
stiamo preparando una missione di nome
solar orbiter vorremmo lanciare nel 2019
forse 2020 che continuerà a studiare
questo immenso reattore nucleare che ci
dà l'energia per tutto quello che
facciamo qui sulla terra e tutto quello
che succede nel nostro sistema solare
dipende dal nostro dal nostro sole
stiamo lavorando molto attivamente sulle
missioni per marte stiamo preparando un
rover che vorremmo lanciare nel 2020 far
atterrare
marx del 2021 perforare la superficie di
marte per un paio di metri per elevarne
campioni e vedere se marte ospita o ha
ospitato forme molto elementari di vita
siamo inoltre per quando una missione
firma giusta per jupiter ai simoon
explorer vuole andare a esplorare le
lune ghiacciate di giove giove come un
mini sistema solare che non si è formato
completamente le sue lune ghiacciate
contengono acqua e l'acqua lo sappiamo è
l'ambiente ideale per lo sviluppo della
vita questo è quello che vogliamo fare
nei prossimi anni continueremo a cercare
ma soprattutto non fermiamo la curiosità
dell'uomo
grazie mille per la vostra attenzione
[Musica]
[Applauso]